with looters raiding stores some
shopkeepers are taking up armed the mid
rising rage in the streets of Minnesota
protests in Minneapolis have swelled
over the death of George Floyd seen on
video gasping for breath as a police
officer knelt on his neck as mourners
held a vigil at the spot where it
happened prosecutors and the FBI
promised an aggressive investigation of
the officers involved I am pleading I am
pleading with individuals to remain calm
and to let us conduct this investigation
that was not what demonstrators wanted
to hear and on the streets it showed the
announcement of a high-profile news
conference had many expecting criminal
charges against the police but
investigations take time and for many
protesters after so many incidents like
this across the u.s. patience has simply
run out peaceful protests turned into
riots with looters smashing store
windows and setting fires that engulfed
entire city blocks in Minneapolis police
responded with tear gas and rubber
coated bullets at the mayor's request
Minnesota is sending in the Army
National Guard this could be a point in
time when several years from now we can
look back to know that we rose to right
the wrongs of the past not just with
words but with action in New York and
other cities across the u.s.
demonstrators join in increasingly
contentious protests and a growing array
of public officials want the officers
already fired from their jobs to face
serious charges
we did see a murder on TV and it wasn't
self-defense at the home of the officer
who knelt on Floyd's neck protesters
have written their own verdict with the
embers of the riots and a community's
angers still smoldering finding out if
prosecutors reach that same decision
could take weeks possibly months to
answer John Hendren al
Zera Chicago